yeah you would have scooted over all
that sweat
all right and you just got off a plane
and you did that imagine what
imagine what you could do if you weren't
i'm always right about 54 years old
always ready
like that's that's how i think of it
that's why that's why i gave you that's
why i give you a benefit of the doubt
because i'm like oh he's hanging with
them
he just got off a five-hour flight from
toledo
yeah you know that's not a close fight
welcome it's not a good morning but
wrote first
for three hours couldn't write it i got
so mad about myself with three
yeah right up man yourself look in the
mirror what happened
you rachen did you did you go did you go
to sleep on the plane
uh first of all lol comedy club i'll see
you this weekend
san antonio okay yeah you guys caught me
better
yeah i watched it go down and i i've
never witnessed something like that
because i'm like i know i've never seen
this i always see you all touching stuff
and i go one day this is going to happen
yeah it happens usually
i thought i thought to myself i might go
i might come at brendan
oh today oh because you saw that you saw
the the chat on the web
i just saw your own black belt yeah and
i didn't like that you were slunching
that i
it makes me i was tired i'm against the
wall
dude you were trying to make yourself as
tall as everybody else that you were you
were hunched you looked like
you had a little you had a hunch you
looked like you had a tummy ache you
were like you do
stand up because otherwise they get as
mad as that hat makes me see i i don't
the whole thing makes sense it sucks
though you can't do [ __ ] about it
that's so frustrating i can come in here
in a full gown
you can't do [ __ ] just like just like uh
logan jake
jake paul jake logan and jake you got
that the way it changed
see that see that it's so amazing how
might my channel go daddy
that's the role you can't reach my you
can't hear me out of toledo okay i came
in five
i i was little you're awake i'm awake
well i got up at three in the morning
the muse hits me i started writing till
six yep because i couldn't i didn't
write
it i got so mad at myself i couldn't
write all weekend i'm just pacing back
and forth watching youtube
in my hotel room and then i then you got
on the flight and you were like i'm
coming
at brendan yeah and then i went to bring
it doug did you see yourself on the
plane yeah
because you got to sleep on the plane
you missed a good time in denver man
god it's nice out there i forget how
nice the weather it's just everything
everything it's so clean
run a better operation than l.a they
they run out that's like a lot of i
think a lot of people do
they run a better operation in l.a
there's no doubt
it's just everything's clean it was so
nice tell me about your all my
so yeah so i flew out there and then
amal easton who i started
with and then uh elliott marshall who
run the school at easter who's the
who is the gracie uh hansel gracie i'm
all eastenders
he's one of his decisions when you when
you come out of hansel gracie school
real deal yeah you got all your real
deals
so chappelle a lot of different schools
you can come out of with a black belt
uh-huh when you come out of a
if you come out of hanson gracie's
school with a black belt or even a
purple belt
it you wouldn't it'd be like the story
so it'd be like
purple is right below black there's
brown and then there's there's
black but white blue purple brown black
oh yeah but why don't i think it takes
you ten years to get up ten years
minimum to get blackberry to get
yeah this is a guy who trained fought in
the ufc and
he told me how he had to do it and i was
like because you haven't you haven't
gotten down like that
in a minute it rolled like that hardcore
in a hot second yeah
black belt all honesty i looked at my
dad i went i haven't rolled competitive
like this in about two years dad
i said we'll see how this goes tiger's
watching he's against the cage i'm like
yeah
you guys you guys are right there
rolling yeah in other words you you
still don't want to get tapped no i
don't know
but then it's like a mall clearly black
belt he just won worlds
no gee worlds it masters elliot who's a
[ __ ] monster
damn and then cody who's a monster yeah
look at it right here the hunched over
christian how are you talking about
jonathan suskin well that no i'm hunched
over how you might well christian
christian so that guy right there
christian allen
which one he's an actual ninja they get
a second to the right he's
that's that's that guy right there is
the baddest mother like he
he he cody told me that cody look at how
big hoodies he's 235 yep
he kicked him in the back of the neck
and he had to sit down for for an hour
like that guy can
you know the little guy that can beat up
huge guys that's that guy he's that guy
he's that good and that guy and his his
his creation in uh
corey sandhagen yeah and he's fighting
tj now that's a difference but all those
guys have
all those guys have been together in a
hot second they all came together for
this so
oh lauren was there landau oh yeah he's
on the picture lauren was there love
lauren
head strength and conditioning coach for
the broncos yeah the whole squad
i got emotional man when they give him a
bike but i started crying you did did
you
yeah because christian was like man
we've had some great times
you have to yeah the best because you
when you walked in there people should
know that when you walked into that gym
you were lost
oh yeah football dream shattered
nightmare you know what i mean like just
didn't know what you were going to do
played tried to play like some indoor
[ __ ] but like people don't realize what
what that is your whole life dedicated
to something and it goes away i guess
i'll try this
yeah you explained it to me earlier you
what you said it's like
they're like oh you get this for six
years or something like that oh i seen
professional sports professional
i told chappelle like imagine if they
were like this how professional sports
careers work for the most part like even
if you had a good career let's say six
years in the nfl yeah good career
so someone can't do it all right brian
from 2021
to 2027 and then after 27 you gotta stop
headlining you gotta figure something
else out
but put you but if you don't put all
your effort into headlining
you're not gonna be [ __ ] so you can't
really do a side gig
because to make it as a headline you
gotta put all your effort into it
it's fast so professional sports it's
like yeah it's you know six years
[ __ ] i talked to i had bruce
gratkowski you know bruce uh do you know
bruce graykowski played behind uh
roethlisberger and pittsburgh and played
in the uh he was a football yeah
a quarterback for 11 years he was good
yeah but never like the guy
yeah well he was behind something yeah
he was but he's a good [ __ ] player
great talking what what smartest guys on
the field are
usually the backup quarterback he's very
real really smart but you just don't
have the athleticism or
the game experience is the best yeah
like the starters
just a different thing man it was it was
interesting to talk to him i love
talking to those guys about the ins and
outs of football like the details
because i
i it's so intricate there's so many
things against you if you play for 11
years
if you even make the nfl that's why
people don't realize like
that that in itself is well like for
instance you get a black belt
less than one percent of all people who
start juice to get a black belt yeah
because it's so you have to stick with
it man think about doing some for 10
years
yeah but also not as a profession like
it's just you're
just doing it yeah typically you kind of
have to compete in something don't you
tip nothing it depends on school right
my school yeah you gotta compete
yeah certain like there's there's black
people specifically you have to yes well
monsters come out there's black belts
there's there's black belts out there
have never competed really
like school black why is why is that
[Music]
they don't they you know there's gonna
that's a choice really though marshall
like this guy's with
all sorts of black belts have never
competed taekwondo that's just a choice
yeah got it okay something against them
okay
to compete it's like a full time but
even and then i think even to get your
brown but it's like less than two
percent get brown belt
it's just a beat so when you when you
were rolling were you the biggest guy
there
ellie's bigger than me is he really yeah
he's bigger probably
yeah was that the guy yeah what was that
like though did you guess
no i didn't i was so worried you work
out all the time yeah i know
and you bike a lot i bike a lot so my
cardio is pretty good
and and and did it is it like riding a
bike did it all come back
but you know you know what's interesting
is you know jitsu now i think dana heard
i didn't listen to her but danaher was
on rogan i would assume they talked
about it but all these guys were talking
about it
the game now is different it's leg locks
like that that tunnel of light locks
like all that leg lock [ __ ]
that's what they he's like that's what
all the kids are into now he's like you
know it's just a different animal
it's a whole different thing all those
guys are crushing them man like
like jamal just you know his name's on
it and he built the school he's just
doing his thing and then
getting checks and then elliot runs the
school the biggest school out there and
then
uh christian and cody own high altitude
martial arts they own that gym that has
over 600 students now
when when when i left it had this credit
to cody and his wife and christian
when i left they had 29 paying students
wow that's 600
we talked to him about that like he's a
very good teacher well think about when
he was out here he was thinking about
moving to l.a i was like you need to
open up your own school dude you're a
great coach you said that because he was
thinking about
joining the fbi he's always been a great
coach then elliott with my son
my son learned more in freaking 30
minutes working with elliott and he's
ever learned in his life
he's such a good coach man of course and
then here's
this guy on the right jeff suskin
again when i was fighting i was in you
know just because you see that i was on
tv and you know
my first child was the main event i
didn't have a ton of money man i
couldn't pay for privates
so this guy on the right who's a black
boner far right far right
jeff suskin would work would meet with
me three to four times we can do
privates wow
two hour long privates wow just to teach
me the like
because i had to catch up i had to catch
it
but the first thing i learned was darts
so like me and chris were talking about
you know i was only trained for like a
year but i had a world-class
dars because he taught me like how to be
really dangerous i just had this knack
for darces so i'd enter the black belt
competitions in the absolute
and beat these black belts because i had
a world-class darsh but if you asked me
to do the basics like
shrimp side escape i didn't have it but
i had but i had a gun
you did that to matt mitrione yeah i had
it well by the time i got to matt i was
a legit black belt but yeah but
early on i just had the darts yeah but
then so christian filled that but then
suskin would
constantly work with me constantly
working me at easton's in denver
i don't give a damn that you haven't
done it in a minute no that no
my my only reason but what's crazy this
too is as i was flying back i text
uh suskin was like dude now i'm older
the amount of time and effort you put in
the guy you didn't know
dude is insane that's one of the best
people i know dude
it's insane yeah think about that think
about taking incredible
two hours of your and he's i mean where
would you have been too look at the
difference he made
like just just that selfless person like
that but he saw potential in you
and then that was the i started crying
when i got my black belt straight up
start crying ball i'm blaming it and
then cody donovan goes dude do you
remember when you first came in 2007
so maybe late 2006 i came to high
altitude i was just a big dude and
there's like small guys then i [ __ ]
this small guy
you know by accident i'm like a
guillotine i didn't know and he goes
bam bam straight yeah and he goes but
he's cody's front time he's wait to my
friend [ __ ] cody
so he's gonna [ __ ] you up was like oh my
god what then cody walks in me and cody
your best friend since day one
cause he's like what's up dudes and
we're your best friends today
yeah i mean cody can skip a beat that's
that's kind of friends
who's as strong as he doesn't know
anything you just go no
he was like a purple belt he's like my
friend cody comes he's gonna [ __ ] you up
i think cody [ __ ] were best friends
you know the one thing i'm sorry about
is i never went down the rabbit hole of
jiu jitsu by the time i came to it i was
i think i was just too old you're just
too busy
busy you're busy yeah it's such a
beautiful it's infinite
like it's infinite it's an art form i've
tried it
i disagree with him on a lot of that
stuff well he was no he was saying
he's like oh because your cheer
background cause you can do all the
flips i mean it's just different
but to me i'd ask what do you want to do
exactly because if your
goal is to learn jiu-jitsu and you're
really into jitsu yeah do jiu-jitsu
it's going to be a 10-year process yeah
but if it's to get in shape
don't do that and post it around the
time hit meds go kickball
kick it back for 10 minutes let me know
how you do like around the time
you're hard on your body too i mean it
can be it can be but also just takes a
long time to get good and get
fun it takes a long time well plus
around the time he like
you know sent me through it out like i
didn't have any money or anything like
that that's the other thing
it was just like expensive it's
expensive and i was like you know like
don't get run like it was it was pretty
cool and interesting to learn but i was
just like man this is
i was like it's just like i was like i
moved out here with stand-up comedy you
know like not
and not even like to disrespect that you
know i gave it a shot but
but it's just it's not it's just like
commitment and then you gotta you get to
pay 250 dollars a month probably yeah
most schools you know what i do
real big commitments hustle as a
stand-up yeah
you know this weekend i went down the
rabbit hole of john donahue and i lit he
gives these like
talks like these philosophical talks
about
man's man for a long time had to fight
for survival
and once we mastered that the need
shifted to meaning
and it's really hard to find meaning
he's [ __ ] you most and he's the
simplest too you know that
he's a minimalist yeah he has like one
spoon
one bowl he wears a raspberry always
john donner he's got his i think he's
got his phd star johnny where's viewers
like with khakis everywhere he goes
really he's got
he's got his phd or like that's right
you know brian we're the same [ __ ] every
day
he does the same it's just the guitar
he's always in that even at a wedding
he'll wear that so someone saw him at a
bar in that
yeah i've seen him every time i see him
in new york he was all right i saw him
at whole foods
that dude taps the best world like he's
moving like this he's just like dude
like cale sanderson you struggle with
craig kidd's
where's where's he located new york new
york okay manhattan
just unbelievable man that's a whole
different mastery level
oh you'll love this you'll love this
so i won't say who it is because i don't
want to get [ __ ] so we're at dinner you
know
my dad you know that's smart dude and
this guy you know we're talking about
politics and
california and trump and all this stuff
and my friend
right when he definitely called god you
better be ready to go just like you know
when we talk
to your dad yeah and he goes i just
can't stand kamala harris i just
i can't [ __ ] stand her and i can tell
my dad's taking it in
and he goes yeah i mean she's just she's
just stupid and the stuff she says
and my dad he's listening i'm like oh
man he's going to set this fight he has
no idea what trap he's going to do
my dad goes now i hear your dislike for
kamala harris
um which which uh issue do you really
have a problem with that
and the guy's like you know just like
and he's looking he's like
she's just she's just stupid she goes no
you you know you keep saying stupid [ __ ]
but give me something yeah he goes what
did she what politician what policy did
you
pass that you disagree with because i
mean god and i'm like oh dude come on
you're [ __ ]
digging a hole here no she just you know
like
you know all of it you said all of it
all of it
every every every every policy it was
everyone i in my day goes
but which one in particular i'm like all
right stop my dad obviously you don't
know what the [ __ ] you saw
yeah oh you don't know i think he's
talking about when she was like attorney
general and like
put all those african-americans in
prison for marijuana
yeah that's that's a problem but as it
goes he didn't say that because he
doesn't know i mean he doesn't know and
you could have given a [ __ ]
get out of jail free pass man it was
just so awkward
everyone's listen i'm like dude please
no apologies your dad's super
intelligent with that stuff yeah well
his dad is his dad is evidence-based so
his dad has a point of view that he's
earned
it's when they have an opinion it's
another thing to have thoughts is
right yeah so opinions everybody has
thoughts
if you if your opinion is backed up by
research and thought and
and and you know and you can and you've
got architecture to keep it
where it is that's called that that's
when you've earned your opinion right
so i grew up with my father and i have
an opinion like that i grew up with that
from day one
where am i friends when you start doing
something my father was in front of
everybody that's [ __ ]
fun everybody my father would say he'd
go yeah well i
i wouldn't i i i guess i could romance
your argument i wouldn't in the real
world but i'll do it here if you like
you know if you want
[ __ ] you do that he'd start with that
i'd be like i love it
you know how i broke the awkwardness my
dad made these burgers
and they're terrible as for my medium
rare it was my dad basically seared both
sides and tossed on there's blood
sneaking outside and so i'm like it's
real awkward my dad keeps tearing i'm
like hey dad this burger tastes like
[ __ ]
and he's like excuse me i'm like you
didn't even you didn't do it i was just
trying to change stuff like
it's like ahi tuna man you seared both
sides this isn't
medium rare and he's like what he's like
and it was just out of the blue
and that's what i was trying to fail my
hair yeah
but in a way it's how it should you need
those people man you need this
i don't like it i have reason i'll give
you a reason yeah but if you don't know
what you do don't talk to somebody
walks the walk man when he's doing i was
like oh my god i did that to my dad when
i was old enough to know better about um
the [ __ ] was her name who was uh she was
she she was the alaska governor oh
and uh i had just i had just been
listening to things and i saw some clips
and i went and i said something to the
effect of i go i mean she doesn't even
know
she doesn't even know any of the supreme
court justices i don't sound like that
my father went
how many can you name you
and there were people around and i was
old enough to do the math
do the math and i was like i can name it
i changed the subject ginsberg
and i'll go i'll go and scalia and my
father goes good that's two
yeah she's gone she named more so i'm on
my way embarrassed beyond being
embarrassed like and i deserved it
i love people like that though i love
people like that oh he's very strange oh
yeah yeah oh you know what i started
reading that book
fox catcher actually most people saw the
movie yeah you
read the book but no that's about dupont
no so the book by martin schultz who
wrote it so okay that's where the movie
comes from
you don't realize how [ __ ] off the
movie is compared to the book
oh really it's really so funny i mean
that's why martial's so upset
because he's like dude a lot of [ __ ]
didn't happen like so
where do you even start so you know mark
schultz and dave schultz never
lived on the dupont they they never
lifted it they
no they lived off campus they were never
at the dupont
farm so this guy dupont was an heir to
the dupont you know dupont and highline
so he he loved wrestling but he's really
total nerd and crazy
i only know it based off the movies he
loves wrestling it'd be like it'd be
like me loving mma and having a lot of
being super
rich yeah and then opening a school and
then i could hang out with you and then
having francis gonna come to your
[ __ ]
camp yeah and then you're trying to be
in his corner yeah so you know and
dupont never cornered him
never i believe that he never cornered
him especially in the olympics he never
did
any wrestling never told him any
techniques mark and dave hated them they
couldn't stand
they were told if they took the job
where he was a wrestling coach at
villanova
if he took the job there because mark
i'm sorry dupont
put so much money in the school they
start the wrestling program and then
dave and mark would
coach there but they they were only
gonna do it if
dupont stayed out of the way they
couldn't stand him he had such bad
dandruff
it caked up on his head his teeth were
so bad that he was a drug addict
he's crazy he was always on drugs or
high all the time
and then you know how in the i don't
know why that describes in the movie
you know how he like has a disdain for
horses because of his mom
well the reason why hates horses when he
was like i think a teenager
he was riding a horse and fell off
really bad and it hit him in the
testicles
and it ruptured his testicles and he got
infected so he got castrated
so he doesn't have no no nuts oh both
that's good so he's cat so he didn't
have a
sexual drive so in the movie when they
make him like
gay and like rubbing on mark schultz
mark's like that what the [ __ ]
like he didn't even have a pair of nuts
like doesn't make sense that's that's
that's that was probably the actor steve
carell doing something
that no that was written yeah the
narrative was that there was a weird
like
gay relationship then mark's like get
the [ __ ] out of here
it's insane you know you read the book
compared to the movie yeah
no matt cause i actually like the movie
i liked the movie too
before i read the book when you read the
book like the movie it will disgust you
but it's also like license and you can
say that about a lot of documentaries
right like
people from there's always an agenda
with documentaries you're telling a
story it doesn't mean it's the truth
right right yeah the whole thing yeah
the whole thing is just [ __ ] weird
man
it's weird but also in the movie you you
think like mark one some blossom
like oh man like they show them losing
in the trials first of all especially in
the year that they showed in 1988
well he might be considered the best
amateur wrestler of all time a monster
he won 99.9 of his matches it was never
close
he's one of the if not the best of all
time so in the movie it's like oh
and then also in the movie you know how
they make him like emotional like punch
himself
yeah mark's like collect the [ __ ] that's
a gold medalist you don't you don't yeah
but you don't get a gold medal mark's
like no you don't get a gold medal being
match and risk [ __ ] not making weight
that now that [ __ ]
what people don't know about wrestling
back then is if you were an american
wrestler you did wrestle in that in
international tournaments
but people weren't sharing secrets so
the russians had their bag of tricks
the turks the iranians everybody had
their own styles and bags of tricks so
they would come up with sometimes they'd
come up with a move that you it'd be
like
if you've never seen an armbar or
triangle so the game was always kind of
guarded you can't really
watch tape on guys and really understand
what they're doing it's way too subtle
with wrestling on that level
okay so so well
is that good and he was able to beat the
russians and all those guys and those
guys do it as a full-time job
so did dave and mark yeah but then also
in the movie they like
in those trials they show like there's
only the wrestlers in the crowd and
there's like
like you know that not that many people
well in the real life it was six
thousand sold out screaming fans
i don't know why they made it like this
dark weird intimate it was the olympic
trials dude yeah
six thousand people who gave the
occasion a good movie though yeah good
movies
great movies just who gave the okay but
if you're if you're marketing and dave
schultz
you're gonna be [ __ ] fierce yeah and
also they made it seem like the brothers
like
were polar opposite and like didn't like
each other mark's like dude we people
thought we were twins we'd finish each
other's sentences it was never
what a travel issue though what a
tragedy ever
trial dude oh yeah [ __ ] break your
heart i was
had kids and
what does the real guy look like uh
bringing it's not a good look no he
looks like [ __ ] take a look at him his
teeth were awful he's a guy
like dave and mark couldn't stand them
and they're disgusted by them they don't
want to be around
the [ __ ] flakes his dandruff was so
bad and he went shower
the dandruff built up and there's like
an inch of dandruff on his [ __ ] head
his teeth were all [ __ ] up uh-huh yeah
he uh
he was not exactly the kind of guy you'd
wanna
he's he wasn't really an athlete he was
a strange
and he's not improving the nose they put
on him too man
yeah and like mark and dave were saying
like they never showed him wrestling
moves they're like we would never
disgrace wrestle by showing this piece
of [ __ ] wrestling moves yeah like in the
movie they show them like
david yeah yeah we would
oh that's the one thing that got right
he was such a man he died and brought
him here talking too he just died dude
he would he would throw events
he would have events given himself an
award it'd be a made-up award
really if i accept this award yeah and
everyone's like
that'd be kind of cool yeah i gotta go
he was just a really wealthy man that
was just like
his wealth had been given to him yeah he
never earned anything because he comes
from the
the he never had friends he never had
like real friends have you seen like
what have you seen
like they did a documentary on some of
the richest kids in the world
the heirs to 200 they're not doing well
well they're four
i'm sorry 400 percent more likely to
commit suicide than regular isn't that
weird
i mean it's a children
yeah what do you there's no struggle you
know
you got to be cause it's not yeah i
guess i mean because it's not money that
they earned
you know they just happen to be born
into it yeah so it's like yeah but mark
schultz
he's been i think i don't know if he
went on rogan but he's been pretty loud
how off the move is he's like i don't
know who the [ __ ] decided to make it
like this
he's like there's no game no i gotta
know i gotta read the code somewhere
yeah i think so he does like speaking
engagement stuff like that but he didn't
want the greatest of [ __ ] all time
and he was like never like you know they
may have seemed like he was like this oh
that's the other thing
they made him seem like this kind of
like dumb like jock
no very smart educated dude hey channing
tatum
played him yeah man
he did who would no we know we know
we've all seen the movie
no well channing tatum
the book the book okay just written by
mark schultz yeah
when did this come out uh fox catcher i
think
won a [ __ ] oscar too
or he did i think um that's 24. it's a
good [ __ ] movie
just if you read the book it will ruin
your [ __ ] day yep
corral though he can act god he's good
in that [ __ ] good man
so good hey where it says where's mark
schultz now go to that jen
um max friend in front of directed who's
president all right mark schultz who now
lives in medford sold the rights to his
life story the movies producers and was
consulting the movie worked out with
tatum helped ensure the accuracy
yeah well he did that you didn't get the
fight
what happens is you write the script you
do
and then the studio the brass they don't
give a [ __ ] about your
wrestling no they go they test it or
they they look at it and they go
this they know movies and a lot of times
you know it's not going to sometimes the
truth isn't as fun
exactly but also like yeah so the movie
ends with him fighting ufc because mark
schultz did find the ufc
gary goodrich but they just a they don't
show gary who's a giant black guy
they they him find a white guy and then
also
what they don't show in the movie is he
took that fight on a day notice
he's a badass he took a real a day
notice a real badass
and that's like one of his biggest
achievements man what did he weigh what
did he fight what right
look look it up chin
and he didn't fight too much in the ufc
no he didn't
203 203 that's what he's flying go to
his uh ufc bouts jen
so he was three-time uh ncaa champion
olympic two-time world champion
just one one and one yeah one
and one yeah you beat gary goodrich yeah
they don't
they kind of just end it on that fight
yeah what the [ __ ]
yep oh that was five nine five nine
it's a thick think about his [ __ ]
brother died man
because that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] worst
way isn't it terrible
yeah he had two kids too man two little
kids ah
jesus yeah break your heart yeah yeah
don't use that picture share dog
how old do you think they want to sell a
car there
yeah did he have any work done
i don't know i i don't know what he
looked like when he's young handsome
dude when he's young
yeah that's why they had channing tatum
yeah big big big john was the ref
who's that guy the artist that's a
different one
oh he's great too let's talk about him
60 years oh he's 60. all right it looks
great kenny monday i don't think kenny
monday i remember watching him wrestle
dude we should get mark schultz on the
show
would be a good idea actually i would
love that
i think he's he's in palo alto it was
born palo alto
i wonder if he's still in california
mark schultz music k-mart
yeah well that's a pretty common name
mark schultz
yeah i think so that can't be him no no
maybe he's not on instagram
six year olds aren't in ig no yeah
wolfy's on tick tock just dancing by the
way
i went down the tick tock hole i can't
open it yeah but it's so
it's so hypnotic yeah i'm watching
fighting and i'm watching dancing
not for you and i'm just like i keep
going you're too
people are singing they're 16. no
they're they're adults
because they do different things
majority of them very young no i'm i'm
watching either the fight
i know you're watching or i'm watching
the dancing i'm not the girls
and the dancer hip-hop he's like you're
the hip-hop dancer you like the movie
not young
he no he's interested in hip-hop because
dance with the same song and i'm like
there's a trend yeah get off tick tock
though for me it's not my fault i'm on
instagram and then you find yourself on
the tick tock
oh that's reals you're on the internet
yeah that's yeah that's what it is i'm
doing it
i don't have tic
it's so it's like eye candy yeah
tick-tock below is now in days
parkour just sucks
because it just works against every it
just works for
people like addison ray it just works
for the girls who do nothing but the
stupid tick tock dancer so like you
rest isn't good yeah you can listen to
watching reels what's the
memory some of it says tick tock
educated yeah that's what i do like i
i like if one of my tick tocks i like i
put like a lot of work into doesn't blow
up i'm like [ __ ] this
i'll save it to my phone and then i'll
upload it real quick
better there sometimes yeah because i
get reels on fire in the kit or mine
i do fighter and kid reels yeah i do
reels uh
dude i don't know do i real do i reel no
we crazy i don't know oh are you on are
you on tick tock cat
no really i figured she would what what
dancing
i don't dance anymore uh but i'm not i
will do the same thing as ryan where i
am on the instagram reels and people
will repost their tickets
got it here's what brian did if i'm
being honest yeah what do you do
a hotel room in toledo or the outskirts
not at all holiday inn no i was at the
uh
uh red roof hilton homes
suites the home number two sweets
yeah yeah and um
go on what daddy do did daddy rent some
porn on tv no no i didn't do that
no doesn't it's an old band move yeah
didn't do it
on the [ __ ] can't watch porn doesn't
do it for me however i
i took a little online tutorial
in hip-hop
that's why i had nothing else to do let
me see if i still got it
i'm blushing and i went well you've
never had it but yeah never
can we see some of your moves and i was
like i was doing this with my
heels and then i was so bored out there
and i was trying to do the moonwalk and
i was like
oh the movie well this is all too
[ __ ] difficult
and i just it's my time has passed what
i love about you you just try
i try to just try it i don't go for it
did you i [ __ ] love it i was like
maybe i'll start hip hop dancing yeah
that'd be sick would you give it a shot
you would have never known what you may
smell amazing go get my black buttons
yeah i'll see you in 10 years and it's
still not going to happen would you give
it us
what what old video was watching i was
trying to do
it did you have danny how much did you
have after you got out of that i was
sitting i was doing this look alone
and and i put on my shoes and i was
doing and then my knee kind of
tweaked a little and i was like this is
the i have to talk about this
the move is tough i sat down like this
and then stared at my screen to write
nothing happened
it's tough when i'm writing when i'm
trying to write i will do weird [ __ ]
mm-hmm i'll i'll go down the oh yeah i
don't do the hip-hop anymore though
i did how would you dance he did a real
punk-rock concert
video did you post videos
legit yeah i was back home in arizona
chappelle you're a legit rock star i
know thank you cat that was very nice
that's a huge crowd
yeah that's huge it's i mean it's it's
it was really really hot
don't turn up too loud
what bothers me is the crowd's not into
it enough for me bro you know how hot it
is
i don't care it's [ __ ] one time i
know but they could still give you that
one
yeah i told you about the gym team i
love how i love the diversity yeah
that's what he said he said he learned
the diversity he said he has about i
said was this a trump rally
you know this is a magazine look at this
christian go to my story
do you know the group bad brains dude
yeah that's what the song we're doing
thank you how do you know that come on
dude that's my jedi look at it
it was pretty cool bags bad brains
is that is that a bad brain song are you
the youngest now that
now the guitar guys yeah those are the
way listen to what i say
what do you say thank you good night
[Music]
i said i feel like a rock star this big
island mike
oh gee yeah mike did some time or what
yeah those are some shots
the stage and there you go i love this
no it was it was it was a lot of fun man
i mean were you nervous yeah i even said
it i said yeah i'm nervous i
just i mean everybody was just
everybody's so nice but you knew that
so what in the [ __ ] ah i need to know
the backstory of this
have you never listened to chappelle
ever
it it is pretty funny when people ask
because they're like
how did this i'm like i mean what are
you going to realize i mean this
this has been me since i was a kid you
know people nobody people anyone who
leaves that comment doesn't know
yeah it's pretty funny but that's like
that's like me in my black and feeling
like man this is weird how did this how
did you end up going down this road
hey guess what a lot of a lot of uh punk
fans are fans of this show
really yeah yeah yeah a lot of them came
up to me were taking pictures with me
because they
like yo i'm a fan of fighting with kids
stuff like that yeah a lot of them
are fans of this show [ __ ] took what was
cool and just [ __ ] threw it out and
everybody
it was kind of cool we did the same like
it's pretty much like how we did it like
how
how we go out on the road we get an
airbnb that was that's what's your
favorite who's your favorite punk rock
band of all time
my favorite punk rock man of all time is
probably black flag black flag
rollins yeah what's up dude bro i got to
touch you
look at me like this is my generation
you weren't born
when they came out
i remember going to those concerts and
i'd be on stage yeah
oh so you go back in the day yeah i was
it like it was called the noise in
brooklyn
it was the first time i ever saw harley
who was the he's a black pencil black
yeah harley had his uh he was playing
the bass and he
walked out onto the crowd when i say he
walked out like they were holding us
like this they were whole like he
was like jesus water yes
he was the first guy i ever saw he and
john joseph the first guys ever saw that
were just covered in tattoos that was in
first generation
well that was in 1989 sir yeah and and
well that was in 1980 788 and 89.
it was where thompson square park would
look like a shanty town
and they found tetanus and the plague in
the soil when
they cleaned it out yeah lori's side was
[ __ ] crazy but harley
hartley was always naturally just jack
those dudes the crowmags they they ain't
no punks man they they
like no jobs those are those dudes are
[ __ ] john was the real deal
they got some crazy stories crazy
they got they they're some tough
[ __ ] harley had that tattoo
look at him
he's 15 years old look at that dude yeah
punks are puncture shredded
oh yeah doyle from the movies he's
always been muscular right type in doyle
from the misfits
when they were kids look at him he's a
kid
you see how big this [ __ ] discipline
dude to get his black belt from henson
but when he had those tattoos that
before that was before anybody was
getting biggest [ __ ] like
that dude yes he looks like the dude
he's a vegan sting yeah he's a vegan too
and he's natural
he's uh he's eating lettuce full of
steroids no he's not he's vegan
leave my boy alone
he's got a protein powder out yeah no
doubt you know what he's eating
he's eating thomas filled with decades
yeah
he's on steroids you ever seen rollins
back in the day he was jacked right he
was rolling
on him i see him on auditions yeah i see
him on missions all the time
yeah he's done a
punks work out yeah you know now a lot
of punks take steroids and i don't think
i don't think henry he's natural he
would never touch i think no [ __ ] he
only drinks uh carrot juice
no steroids filled with a chick
quit talking about that's henry right
there yeah yeah that's young henry long
hair
now he's a savage that was yeah um that
was probably his latter years of
i'm telling you we're gonna do 9 30 club
in dc and you're
going to wear henry rollins all those
guys i have like that club
henry henry henron's autograph and all
his pictures are all over oh really
yeah oh [ __ ] dude ian mckay all those
guys have hair like that
yeah i didn't know you were going to the
shows back in the day yeah
that's amazing that is amazing did you
go to one
and i was down there we heard the
stories
the concerts were very close so i could
have gone easily they they offered
yes they are i could have there's that
that i chose
why do you yeah why'd you do this with
your favorite
i mean i don't remember maybe i did i
don't remember
a long time ago like in dc i'm sure i
went to a fugazi concert or one of those
i don't know
a picture of it because i mean i don't
know dude
he knows
didn't stevie get tickets cat to rage uh
yes i think we might have gotten
two tickets he's going to two different
locations
with who by himself there's only friends
he doesn't know anyone else i'm going
with him wait oh yeah you're going with
me
i miss stevie i haven't talked to him we
should call him right now even the
road's different we never
[ __ ] that's stevie's house he's
different now
he looks different he looks different
his hair is growing out he's got a
breeze that he's
running slowly he how's he going how's
his eye his eye is doing better
we have a check-up appointment for him
tomorrow good
but yeah he's doing good he looks like a
completely different person
he doesn't look like the guy i met last
year
where did you guys go tin we went to
quarters because for his late birthday
uh
he and i were supposed to go for a while
and then it kept getting pushed
so we went randomly i think a month
later what is stevie doing right now
right now like like at this moment
like grow out a cool beard huh i would
say you would have to ask him
he's amazing at being able to just hang
yeah yeah
work out for five hours yeah i can't do
it we miss him on that i took him to
the on it like jim and he's like no
mirror's here i'll see you later
like why why yeah jumping on the ropes
and he goes how's that jumping rope
you're doing all that functional fitness
yeah
steady goes to the race
yeah very smart he's good at everything
he did tries mm-hmm yeah it's just that
he can't hold his attention
no he just has to pick a lane yeah but
that's okay he'll figure it out he's
good yeah just hanging out
he is annoying to uh work out around
though because you're right he always
has like opinion
on working out so i'll do one thing and
then he gives me he's just
like that he knows the game looks great
his body looks absolutely him and mark
harley together
oh they would love him oh they would
work out really [ __ ] each other
yeah they would why are you gonna make
it sorry
why does that have to come to that last
week looks like he's as big as you are
is he is he really
do 40. oh he's he's leaner he's a big
boy oh yeah
yeah i've seen him right yeah yep
where'd you see him at uh he did catch
up
i met him a few weeks before i think you
guys all uh hung out yeah
he played college football yeah oh he
did yeah where uh
no pomona i think he played pomodoro no
it's not no
no division three division yeah he paid
he's very he's very honest about it he's
very honest which is great very honest
he doesn't try to like up
i'll play his bunch of volleyball
players on my flight on the way back
here
men are women d1 men played at uh sc
oh got it yeah q1 guys very very tall
fellas
not the most popular guys i want to ask
you a question i want to ask you an
athletic question
why you got to stop with his [ __ ]
billboard he's going somewhere
oh yeah i'm going somewhere with it now
they look like athletes the volleyball
but especially if they're southern cow
they're monsters
they're monsters best of the best is
there though
like do they jump up and spike each
other's dicks in their mouths
maybe that's not what i was gonna say
okay that's like the professional soccer
of this hockey player i met with steve
byrne and i go i go
did you do other sports because yeah i
played soccer but i decided i didn't
want to suck [ __ ] all the time
jesus christ it's so rough i'm going to
ask you a question
yes we're just talking right and i
respect all athletes yeah
a lot of times if you play football in
the d1 school and the rugby team's over
there you look at them and you go you
guys didn't make the football team i've
heard
you guys do that okay is there anything
is
when you see the the volleyball players
they're six
five six six six seven six eight yes
gorgeous
did they not make the basketball team is
that what happened
no i'm one man in california like that's
as competitive
very athletic guys they're monsters
right i would assume they just gravitate
towards
volleyball yeah especially if they're
cal fc right
now you don't think it was like it's
like watercolor like water you've seen
like the sc san diego water polo players
monsters yeah
yeah which is what they gravitate
towards yeah hmm now if they're playing
you know
some other school if they're not in
southern california i don't respect it
if it's hawaii something like this
but yeah if you're a volleyball player
in montana i can play other sports
yeah let's be real i'm the kind of guy
i'm going to make the wrestling team at
university of missouri if you're on the
water polo team at missouri u
you feel me there you go now again do
they jump up and spike each other's
[ __ ] in their mouth
i feel like you're being drunk you keep
saying that because that's what i feel
like they do no
so they can get so high and i'm going to
say
i'm going to say they don't do it no
they don't do that
oh no that was unfair do it again that's
where you're running to be fair you're
not far off i'm going to essie i hear
some rumors about certain absolutely
spiking dicks in the mouth
yeah yeah really yeah
i mean like all the athletic sports just
like guys in those higher up d1
teams like every now and then there's a
few that like to go both ways
sure oh yeah especially these young kids
today they're confused a lot of football
players
i'm confused i don't see the problem for
me i'm in a phase
your [ __ ] looks like part of my face
it is that's what they do i never had a
black man before
what was growing up in my little country
town huh gotta gotta give me a flavor
gotta test the water here we are a lot
weaker
down this dark hole hey why are you
gonna be a dark horn
it might start dark but it gets all
kinds of pain
who are they i'll tell you what was
weird we stayed in this new hotel
um with clayton everyone's like yes the
new hotel in denver yesterday's clean
what the clayton is it's like one of
those new hotels and i'm all for it but
everyone there is transgender or like
gay like the whole staff
this is it's just what they go for so i
went to check in i'm with tiger you know
we're getting
he loves his favorite thing on the plane
that's hotels it's like disneyland town
so we go to check and i was getting cool
hotels because he loves all the hotel
stuff
[ __ ] with the phones and eats all the
treats so we got to check in
it's a it's a dude big dude all right my
size
dress dress big beard and then
full like mascara and full blown like
long
nails just you know typing in yeah and i
go what's up bro
because i i didn't see the dress like
what's up bro you can tell he's like
pronouns and gave him his pronouns oh he
did yeah and then tiger goes dad is that
a boy
and trying to describe it to a
five-year-old i go it is a boy
it is but now did he say i'm a she or
what is this no his pronouns were i
forget they them themselves
i was i was it's just if you don't know
i don't know i was getting like
when we go up the hotel my son's like
dad that's a boy i'm like yeah it
it it's complicated for a five-year-old
you know because they have no filter
especially the they
them one is a little harder it is a boy
it is a boy who likes to dress like a
girl most transgender people
identify as one sex with the other it's
very rare that you see people say i'm
not
this guy wasn't mean
my pronouns are they them but no he's
like oh dude uh my pronouns are i was
like oh that's cool
they i had that happen to me i didn't
know how to use it although
i was getting coffee and and the person
had long
beautiful hair eyelashes that was that's
and that's
that's your makeup that's a gorgeous
brazilian crush on her i have a crush on
her i'm not gonna lie
little haze yeah we both have a crush on
her ass
and it took us a long time to break that
shell yeah because she was
very mean very mean us she was mean to
you guys well
not anymore she was all she goes through
daddy died is working well thanks girl
i'll take the usual
wait right here yeah yeah i'm talking
about brazil and i'll [ __ ] all the time
sometimes
sometimes you give me a free [ __ ]
american pretty pretty pretty pretty
girl
pretty pretty but i i i said i said look
at it i'm jealous of his hair in his
eyes
and uh the person said she
and i went you see i'm an old man and i
apologize for that
she and she goes you're fine it's all
good that's how it should be
yeah most well yeah i don't think it's
funny how we did all these things become
the norm after a while all these things
after a while it's like you know it is
it is what it is
it's tough with kid like the tiger has
no he doesn't he has no filters so he
saw my mom who we haven't seen she
hasn't seen her in like three years
since he was
two and doesn't know where that well
walked up he's like oh you look old
grandma i'm like hey
buddy i was all
buddy she can't really say that she's
like why i'm like
because it hurts people's feelings dude
but she's old i'm like
you're right or when you're right you're
right he's right i'm getting he doesn't
look
old i'm getting my coffee a blue bottle
and there's there was a woman who was
big and my daughter was young and my
daughter just went
daddy she is she's daddy she
is so fat yeah oh kids don't know
we've been lying at starbucks and
there's just a girl a [ __ ] honker
like a [ __ ] shark fin like this like
[ __ ]
dupont like the chris you know like
[ __ ]
yeah knows that like you won't want to
invite her at a cocaine party right now
and like like jeremiah watkins knows
like oh okay on like that's in america
you can't miss this yeah
dad her nose hey dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you man yeah
that's
kids are they they there's something
yeah that's how it is
and then they'll just fart too man just
farts
and be like excuse me i'm like dude
don't they excuse me because that makes
it worse
yeah just fart dude just fart no kidding
little fart yeah that's right
just let it teach my son how to wipe his
ass was a [ __ ] like he'd just be like
to be generally it would be [ __ ] when
you have kids man it's like
did you wipe your ass on the wall yeah
especially boys i feel like boys are
slower to catch on to stuff they also
won't shower
girls are clean my daughter from the age
of three
was wanted a clean place setting she
wanted a clean
not like napkin my son my son
i'm telling you would never brush his
teeth or wash they boys don't give a
[ __ ] about taking a shower tiger has ocd
like his body oh he does he's super he's
bad yeah ben at this time shower brushes
teeth
and all even like do like i'll be like
you want to brush your teeth tonight
let's just get
like no i need to brush my teeth i'm
like yeah right [ __ ] bruh
with my son i'm like i'm like dude it's
not a big deal your dad would only brush
him once a day let's just [ __ ] he's
like no
he's like we gotta brush my teeth and my
god
that's so funny man i'm the same way i
said come on man
and then really me getting my black belt
started with him we went to school and
he's like dad dude those guys are black
well do you think you'd beat them i'm
like what do you think
i'm like yeah yeah definitely could he's
like you're black but i'm like
yeah i'm a butt he's like well i've
never seen your black but i'm like well
i don't technically
have it he's like so you're not black
like all right dude
so i'm going down i toss them like
[ __ ] take your belt bud
dude my daughter does [ __ ] like this to
me like i she's i said
i said her she's 13 and she's smart and
she reads a lot
and she and i go the hobo got this hobo
outside
and she she goes really a hobo oh is
that so it's his fault he's
homeless that he has no home i guess
i guess you you take credit for
everything that you've done i like it
jesus
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this i go
yeah i just take it down
yeah don't talk to me like that you're
13. you can teach me nothing
you teach me nothing i teach you
everything you can't teach manage
because i can teach you nothing i go
that's correct
you can teach me nothing and i teach you
everything so don't talk to me that way
because i know everything and you don't
because you're 13.
that's what that's how i try to win the
argument she goes okay so i can teach
you nothing okay she goes good
what's the first layer of the atmosphere
i was like your favorite game you like
you still like hide and go seek so don't
talk to me
yeah yeah you're still in the tag yeah
she's she's a smart kid
[ __ ] with you well you know because in a
way she's right
yeah i'm a hobo what's what's weird is
uh
jay brought tiger a game he brought him
uh smash smash
bros oh yeah super smash bros that's
such a big i didn't realize how big of a
game it is
there are leagues so many kids make
money doing that yeah you're super into
it now
dude my son loves mortal kombat could it
be more violent
do you guys play video i don't play
these games motor combat's always been
viable
i have to take it off the [ __ ] game
or the [ __ ]
cutting i take it off the switch it's
it's outrageous
yeah and i like fatalities i learned how
to do them and i do them entirely like
yeah like this is not good dude my sons
i had to get
gay it's so violent what the [ __ ]
they've always been violent though
really yeah mortal kombat that's always
good but now dude
graphics are better now oh really he's
violent too
call of duty man what what is the one
where you just have a gun it's called
call of duty yeah dude that [ __ ] is and
you're fighting other people
right halo halo's like aliens so i can i
can
see real people i can't see people
getting into that [ __ ] like really doing
it smash bros is so addictive i was
playing on the plane the entire way back
he was like dad can i return like
you're going to wait god damn it we're
going to be we're going to fight
wars like that 100 there's a robotics
war going on right now have you seen
that what
boston dynamics is doing with those with
robots that dance have you seen that
[ __ ] yeah
i see the robot do a back flip take a
look yeah if you show it they didn't
push them over not really no you can't
you can't push over those those dogs and
stuff
they're [ __ ] try kicking them over
have you seen that one
where the things holding the shotgun
like that robot or that [ __ ] thing
over
it's ridiculous is it a new one they
released yeah
watch this five months ago dancing
watch this this is the future and
they're gonna put skin on it
what's that movie with shiloh is this
the thing that you watched to teach you
the moonwalk you're thinking of eagle
eyes
the movie was shiloh above where he's
fighting off robots well that's coming
watch this
but you're also thinking of my robot
with will smith oh that's
white robots oh that's kind of are they
white
look at this [ __ ] look at this
this is going to be it's going to be
this is what how i'm going to trip that
stupid you can't trip that thing we're
going to fight
no you can't you cannot yeah how can you
not trip that thing okay just push it
over
show it and then they get up like dogs
watch the guy who tries to kick this
thing over
watch brian in toledo yeah look at that
[ __ ] you that's you and your hotel room
look at that [ __ ] this is cool
okay look at him get it get it a lot of
people think
oh you know i started re-watching
because season four is about to drop
yellowstone
that's why i'm wearing the hat it's a
good show huh that's not but they don't
wear the hat on
they do though they wear them rip
where's they wearing a coffee shop
when you're a barista my boy from daisy
may made it okay so be cool dude
i'm being cool you learn hip-hop videos
in hotel rooms
that's that kind of that kind of way
that kind of brings my head down
i knew i opened up to you and now you're
using it against me sorry that's [ __ ]
amazing
oh my god it's working oh still we're a
wife beater that's cool
it's not 1980. i can't
help it it's a habit it makes me just
feel secure you can't call me no i don't
you called it there you can call guinea
that's what we call him oh
americanized it like my grandfather like
you know how you when you come over from
europe you can you got to put into
american terms yeah so it's
well it's paolo is the americanized bar
in italian it's paolo
so you know what they call it staten
island bridge what you know what they
call the staten island bridge
no way any gangplank
yeah i mean but if you're italian you're
like don't call me a guinea but then you
know i was just trying to
find out wait i want to see them kick
the [ __ ] dog no [ __ ] those rules
there's one video of a robot holding uh
a shotgun like where they like it's the
future bro
yeah there's a future there's people
messing around they're just having a
good time no it's definitely a feature
it's awesome
robot dominated whatever it's the plot
terminator too dude
watch this [ __ ] watch this thing
i want one i want why are we building
these
i think getting run on ice what is it
for to take over the world dude let's
see where the world gonna be china
100 percent look at that no you're not
kicking it over dude
okay oh no you can kick that thing yeah
yeah well a robot can imagine what it's
going to be like in
20 years oh i know that's how all awards
so it's terminator two man
that's fine you'll be able to fly get
out of here that would be cool to have
as your
little like assistant with fantastic
facial recognition
you're gonna have they have that thing
with facial recognition it's a little
disc that flies and finds your face
lands in your head and shoots a bullet
in your head you seen that you're living
in the
hollywood yeah no i'm not that's an
invention hey you know it was like a
story when you told us about how your
mom said the bus
don't wear a scarf on the bus that's
what you're doing right now chin bring
that up you know what's happening right
now
you have too much time in hotel rooms
you're watching too many videos you were
a little impressed with my strength when
i'm done
not at all i was impressed by me
benching
400 pounds a lot of weight it's a lot of
weight dude
400 pounds i will rip your teeth you're
kind of wrapping rip your teeth up
yeah i'm going to go for 4 15 this you
can do that to me
i bite your [ __ ] finger you know what
i wish you were coming to miami with me
do this logan paul floyd mayweather
fight
it sucks going by myself when are you
going because maybe i'll come thursday
i gotta be in lol let me tell you when
you get you doing nope
san antonio yeah i haven't done that
saturday
are you sure special there it's a beast
oh it is big tall ceilings uh-huh louis
san antonio's just great try it up [ __ ]
it what no
i'll be in wisconsin oh that's right
apple appleton dude
yeah let me check chappelle's schedule
for you no he can't
hey they're not giving those those rooms
away at hotel home are they no
yeah not for you all right won't we look
at red roofing
no i'm going to stay don't do the red
roof yeah you got to stay at hotel got
to stay
i mean you see me half your pay but just
[ __ ] do it
worth it yeah that's my favorite hotel
on the planet
it's the best hotel on the planet yeah
on the planet yeah
we're gonna say uh i i
fly coach a lot of times because i'm
smaller that makes me sad because
because
because i go i go i'm flying to new york
and i go that's thirteen hundred dollars
worth of four hundred dollars for five
hours and i feel like i'm getting ripped
off
so i will sit in delta comfort yeah and
read i do that yeah comfort is great
first big people comfort's gonna give a
[ __ ] i just feel like i'm being taken
care
of
no doubt dude now if i'm going to europe
you keep playing huh
what are your daddy's fighting first
first class business business
first is ten thousand dollars yeah yeah
sometimes
it's too expensive oh you're not doing
no you don't do business
am i the only one here watching
yellowstone i think so
i've seen like one or two episodes i've
been trying one real chin
[ __ ] album you're from
texas how do you know i lived it man i
lived it
i don't need to watch it you did oh yeah
i lived i actually worked on
i sort of like a farm you did you worked
out my cousin's place yeah you know what
you know what i'm too bad about it about
dick
jeff bezos worked on a farm because i
didn't realize it never happened yeah
grew up on a no
grew up on a goddamn grew up like
castrating cows and all that i was like
whoa oh [ __ ]
who am i spent his summers on ranch who
am i
jeff bezos dude he'll shut us off
yeah no he's not on youtube he owns
amazon so my package will come a day
late
that is so mean where's my camera i
don't approve of this but he doesn't
he doesn't care he's got he's gonna get
you you wanna see his girl fifty what do
you wanna do is girl yeah let's see it
oh where is your girl you don't see this
girl let me see this girl
hold on you are a bad guy huh you never
see this guy
that's how they discover each other she
went sweet i went sweet eye i haven't no
they linked up yeah
that's i have that that'll throw me off
that that look that's a good one though
that's you're doing it well it's good
it's not bad there well that's a crooked
eye that's what's
where i come from it's called a [ __ ] guy
talking about his sniper right it ain't
great yeah well
some people have a droopy eye but maybe
it's just that picture that's true they
saw each other across the park yeah see
it's just the pictures
no no no no no no no no no no that's
just that picture yeah
bad pictures the muscle's weak that what
happens you have you lose muscle there
there's a weak mind i got your back jeff
bezos
he listens i like him i don't know him
but he seems it looks like he had like
bella's palsy on his face it looks like
he's
[ __ ] he was a sniper he's a sniper i
had a homie that has uh
i had it from or uh whatever one you get
from lyme disease i had in my entire
life the
entire side of the cover thor that huge
guy had one he he had yeah
oh i had a giant my kids had issues
then they grow out and they straighten
up remember when you started having did
you start getting those ocular headaches
where you could you just i'd see like a
prism at one point he was just drinking
coffee and like just basically dieting
yeah
and then he'd wait what and then he just
go like this he'd go
he starts sweating i'm gonna i gotta go
throw up let me just go throw up
or you just get this [ __ ] like your
boy is gonna be blind he'd go blind
boy's shredded
he was trying to i would go like this
and i was like for me i'm like dude you
gotta go to the [ __ ] doctor is this
what you were fighting yeah
yeah i don't know what it was i don't
know if i was fighting
no you weren't fighting oh you're just
hanging living just trying to get it
no breaks nope yeah that'll [ __ ] you up
man but he won't go to the doctor he's
like
never all right what do you got for us
jen let's take a little break from the
shenanigans with the boys because two
out of three men will experience some
form of hair loss by the
time they are 35 that's right your hair
is leaving there's nothing you can do
about it till keeps came along keeps
offers a simple stress
free way to keep your hair alright uh
it's convenient virtual doctor
all right medications delivered straight
to your door every three months you
don't have to leave your freaking home
low cost treatments are just ten dollars
per month keeps offers generic versions
to keep your freaking hair man discreet
little package
proven results prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so if you want to keep
your hair this year
act fast ready take action prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com
fighter that's k-e-e-p-s dot com fighter
to receive your first month free of
treatment all right
that's keeps k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
fighter
to get your first month free keeps.com
fighter
father's day is coming up my kids better
freaking get me something man what do i
want i want an
on tucket shirt that's right father's
day is june 20th
so you dad's out there get ready if you
haven't found the perfect gift for your
dad look no further
than on tuck it untucked shirts are
designed to be worn untucked
all right so they have comfort built in
they're just the thing to get great and
feel comfortable
all summer long plus on tuck it has fits
for all shapes and sizes
maybe we got skinny dad a thick dad
whatever it is
untuck it got you covered keep your papa
happy most of montauk's gift
ideas are under 100 bucks so you can buy
a gift for dad and get one for yourself
go to ontalkit.com or to get one of 80
plus on target stores nationwide
so remember if you need the perfect gift
for father's day get your daddy
something he wants get him a shirt from
ontucket
shirts designed to be worn untucked use
code fighter for 20
for your first purchase at ontucket
u-n-t-u-c-k-i-t
dot com that's untuckit.com promo code
fighter for twirls off this father's day
which is june 20th
wait what'd you guys do this weekend you
played kickball
oh no no i thought you said i played
football
i had wiffle ball all right come on now
that one's fun
i thought didn't you say you had the
lead off uh or the you ended the game
with a [ __ ] home run
yeah i did i had a walk-off home run
yeah was it with kickball they lifted
you up like a kid
um yeah yeah huh you hundred percent of
town
my grandfather would [ __ ] kill me if
i didn't say this half northern italian
half cisco so i'm sicilian
and not believe don what my mother's my
mother's my mother's
father was sicilian and his her mother
was no from naples
yeah and i'm 20 of talent how about that
only 20 yeah 20. that's
it that's it what's the rest how are you
so dark i don't know dude
that doesn't make any sense jay's pale
what
is your dad i don't know your dad is a
native american 100
is your mom dark nope english and you
did you did your genome yeah 20
italian and you're mostly english 50
english 20
italian and then someone was norwegian
that's so [ __ ] weird
i was hoping that little african in
there you must have
you have no no ottoman no nothing
dark as [ __ ] hey man i've been sick
frank gross 19 sub-saharan african
oh really see i was hoping 19 i was it
was funny because i
remember a while back i was thinking
about doing one of those really
yeah do it no why
what am i going to find out what am i
going to find out you're from west
africa
it's just yeah exactly yeah you wasted
your money i wasted my money yeah you
you stopped it
in the can and mailed it in yeah yeah
and then my mom well i guess yeah i
would do it
to find out vietnamese yeah because she
could have told me it's hard
but western is darker western africa
um it depends it could be but no that
depends on where you are
i mean you do it just to figure out
where you're from and eritreans maybe
you're nigerian
maybe you're from jamaica sudanese are
dark as [ __ ] yeah that's what i'm saying
i mean
that sudanese are very dark the the but
the the it's true that maybe those of
those
uh those are the ones that uh come up to
me and ask if i'm from and i got you
know who doesn't ask where you're from
ethiopians what'd you say
real skinny ethiopians are scared so
what
do you what are you doing you're not
eating you ever seen a fat ethiopian bro
i'm not gonna women the women are so
beautiful
bring up ethiopian or eritrean women
yeah they're beautiful
in women they're on your dna it's like
you don't know okay the
here's where the most beautiful okay
some of the most athletes who's the most
yeah who's the most athletic guy
senegal senegal senegal the biafra coast
they they they according to
the most athletic but nigerians are
that's common well yeah i'm not that
dark look at these women all right
i'm not that like nigerians you see this
[ __ ] commonplace
in ethiopia and eritrea they're all
[ __ ] gorgeous
maybe i'm from ghana look at her is that
technically a part of west africa like
uh
no eritrea and ethiopia are east africa
but uh and the oldest coptic christian
church where they think the covenant
is is in ethiopia so you cannot go back
to somalia
which is on the water uh that's that's a
most predominantly muslim country ghana
ghana somali women are beautiful
also pirates what part is this shotgun
tell them about pirates
um
pirates the pirates were fishermen and
then they couldn't earn a living because
all these commercial fishing boats were
[ __ ] taking off and so they started
jacking the commercial boats yeah then
booker haram or now it was uh
here real quick bring up lambda yep
chicks and it's going to show the most
beautiful ones now there's there's some
ugly people from sudan okay
oh so that's me there's ugly people in
america it's not uncommon to see a seven
footer in sudan by the way if you're a
dancer
yeah yeah minute ball if you're if
you're uh uh
a dinka or a um what's the other what's
the other tribe
no i don't like how you're only clearing
on the real hot ones gin go up for me
i clicked on everyone got two hey you
didn't i did these first this is the
first batch
how are you going how are you going to
try hate i'm not hating you're just not
giving a real picture of
the land now now bring up lambda
senegalese wrestlers lambda yeah
they're the jack guys in the diapers yes
yeah no all right
it'll do it send they go send that guy
senator
senegal man
yo you gotta go there you go
wrestler now take a look at some of
these guys let's go
let's go look at this look at the back
on that one oh and that's not steroids
that's just
uh is that holy [ __ ] that's a six foot
six
guy you enjoy that first of all what is
this oh it's just strictly wrestling uh
yeah it's a type
and i'll tell you who has his hands full
brandon schaub in that group
yeah brendan's not doing that no no now
there's the guy that's the most
winningest guy oh that's me
he's just two body same body he's yeah
he's 260
270 frank guerilla went and did that and
just said they're the biggest strongest
[ __ ] on the planet
yeah yeah you don't want you know part
of that
now did they did the entire stadium fall
and a bunch of people die
yes but uh and they don't serve dodger
dogs
there you go there you go then that's
now i don't want to be back i'd like a
back like that
that could be you look at that hey yeah
that is me you're talking about a high
ass
you could have that body if you would
just listen looks like an average listen
to you
uh we'll oil you down oh ooh i like this
yep
and you guy ain't touching me y'all can
do all the touching yourselves and [ __ ]
that's good
right there bring my bring my boy bring
that bring there it is there's that
look at that damn that's come on sam
that's he's one he's one of those
wrestlers
yeah don't [ __ ] around look at that now
what we're gonna do is send [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh got me down there okay
down there you had a problem with that
you got a problem with that physique
enjoy that [ __ ] i to see this wrestling
uh
maybe is that it was is it not that
crazy i mean look it doesn't matter when
you're built like that
just walk around like that i'd walk
around in that exact [ __ ] alpha i'd
wear that to the studio
of course you would small calves too
calves you don't need calves dude you
don't need calves that's me that's more
my
that's one of my yeah that's more of my
speed right there it's more rotunt
i want to strap myself down like that
yeah yeah that's me
yeah you cover yourself in clay yeah a
lot of people there
oh they're rock stars
what do you got let's go now guys that's
christmas guys
there we go okay so in california there
is
a vaccination lottery where if you are
partially vaccinated you have a chance
of winning
millions of dollars because i got
vaccinated your boy might be
partially 116 million oh wait i get both
vaccinations
it's only hard
i talked to my friend as a doctor who's
like he went through all the things he's
like
yeah some people have the majority of
people don't you you hear the one
percent of people were like oh i had to
drive my own
mark didn't mark didn't feel anything
mark uh hella
mark harley some people have some tough
uh thoughts yeah majority don't though
you know
majority down that's a vaccination a lot
of people die of aspirin people don't
realize 1 000 people
died alone from this vaccine more than
any other vaccine though i don't think
that's trying
what did you say look out for you are
you giving us youtube facts right now
no my brother's like right my oldest
brother is like
all into that shaky i just get my news
from yeah
thousands did not die from receiving the
vaccines
viewed more than 21 000 facebook not a
ton is it hey sometimes you just gotta
hit google there's no evidence
climbing i told you man if they said hey
you gotta get
vaccine in the ass or in the eye i would
do it just to not wear a mask
that's how it came out you know i left
my mask in the hotel room in denver
everywhere was like can wear a mask if
you want or not same in arizona
same in arizona in california it's like
june 15th it's like what the [ __ ] does
what
difference like what special date is
that it kills me how about on planes
it doesn't make sense playing gym
anywhere here anyway
even when you go to restaurants they say
we have lifetime immunity anyway
that's what they say once you've had it
you have lifetime immunity yeah there's
something in the in the
mirror of the bone yeah where they're
saying there's people that say they've
got it twice yeah those people are liars
people those people they're wrong about
those people are full of [ __ ] yeah do
you think they probably never had it or
it was a false positive
yeah but the majority of people again
the majority can't get it again
right and everyone go well there's
another variant
and yeah even the variant you have
immunity too yeah
and all all diseases mutate so these
variants they keep saying that every
disease
mutates try and get in a different host
yes
read a book so the interesting thing
about the uh lottery is that you can
actually win 50 up to 15 million dollars
wait no you went up to 1.5 million
dollars and there's 15 people who can
win you could be 12 years old and win
can i win yes so if you're 12
and up and you've had at least one of
the shots you qualify for this lottery
quit this fight yeah if you're a kid
[Laughter]
brennan is out please quit he's it's
deuces that's your retirement number
yeah yeah jeff bezos but you could be 13
win this and then it's put into a
savings account that only you can touch
upon turning 18 so it's not like your
parents get it
cool which i think i think they've been
doing that now like you were like
usually not for like a lottery before
uh actors yeah yeah mccauley calkin rule
parents took all his money yeah they
screwed them over yeah [ __ ] them over
so they started to
roll against it hollywood did what else
you got
hopefully somebody in here wins what
would you do
johnny i'm sorry christian if you won uh
like if i won 116 million yeah yeah
you're only going home with 80. so be
cool huh that's true you're only going
home with 80 of that
uh honestly i'd probably move out of the
place i live in now get
a nice house deliver roommates no i'd
i'd
pay for a house for all of us to live in
my cool
well my roommates are my two brothers
and a guy who like i'm a really good
be weird if i got a house i'm like oh
[ __ ] you guys yeah um
also yeah i'd probably give them each
five to ten mil
nice guy yeah i mean 10 mil yeah you'll
see when you get them
right no my they're like you can go
broke what you need to do is create that
short king app
but they're his brothers but yeah
they're my brothers and uh my
grandfather's
my sicilian grandfather's like a huge
ferrari fan i like
loves ferrari like he said to me a year
ago which kind of depressed me was like
yeah i think i'm gonna have to finally
give up on my dream of owning a ferrari
uh he's like in his 80s i'm a poster
no if i won the lottery i would buy him
a ferrari
what what spitballing ideas for his
grandfather he can't buy his grandfather
a [ __ ] ferrari poster grandfather
yeah
how insulting is it that was a
honest opinion this is an insult i don't
have one but here you go
just rub it in his face we i'm sure we
could find him a used one
he's he doesn't know he's sold on a
specific one huh yeah you know which one
he wants
i don't know his old age what's he want
like a testarossa those are expensive
no i think he'd want the f-430 or
something like that okay
or the italian one of those four what do
we got what are we gonna do we have to
win the lottery
yeah he's like he's like a high-end like
ferrari yeah
200 000 yeah like yeah either that or
probably the 458
one of those 458 that's how we could
fail for the pizza
yeah he says what's happening for him
yeah if i win the lottery i'll get him
whatever he wanted that's gonna be tough
yeah
what did you drive the money uh like 12.
[ __ ] it
you can just collect it i drove it every
day incredible
don't you have to be like uh selected to
even own one or something like that
what you can't especially a pizza yeah
somebody use those no you can get them
yeah you don't have to be on the wait
list it's best to be on the allocation
list
you have to own like there's guys who
will buy ferraris
just hold on to them because they know
if they buy that ferrari they'll get the
new allocation of the new ferrari mm-hmm
what do you think the sf-90 my gt2 rs
still usually do you love that car i
love it why is that a best car in the
car always
probably never doesn't get better be
tough yeah
what about what about tesla's new nope
hold on
0-60 in one point zero seconds or so i
don't care it's a video game
but dang no but it blows it it destroys
your car
laughs here
hey you know what it is about those
electric cars i just can't get into
sucking [ __ ] and i see you in one of
those
i think to myself listen oh that guy
sucks no
no not i speed by not if i'm gonna be on
the track chin bring up the
fastest [ __ ] no it's the plat it's
the plaid edition
tesla they do you know what you know
what your hair dude when i as i pull
away and it's so funny it sounds like a
fork this is why you're here ready
you hear this you don't care i don't
like that
yeah i don't like that though but why
dude
where it's a hybrid i like the love
ferraris yeah but also there's the
hybrid uh porsche too
the spider take on yeah well the take on
it's full
nineteen sports that's the model thing
oh the 918 oh that's a tesla
yeah dude that's a tesla no no they're
just showing different electric cars
oh got it i was testing the roadster 1.9
seconds
[ __ ] so the tesla would be the
fastest one
that's the tesla right there that one
that's three point one what's the one
you're talking about my car goes 3.1 my
car would [ __ ] all oh wow
yeah but if i get in my roadster
hey do me a favor type in the uh fastest
gas power card
on the um what's the track where they
measure all the cars
oh amg i don't know but these are these
aren't as fast as the electric cars
these are like 360. yeah they're
electrical amg quicker zero to sixty
[Music]
but the one other nuremberg get a
nurnberg that's the only thing that
matters yeah cause like turns and
like straight line nobody gives a flying
[ __ ] about unless you're 18.
tracks we're all about traffic tracks
yeah go the fast car on the track let me
see which one that is
if you could do that for me take it easy
take it easy
what is it oh there's porsche oh weird
okay oh there's the gt3
weird yeah you are sitting right here
okay but
what about the uh no oh we're you know
what's weird tesla's not on there
that's because they haven't brought the
roadster out volkswagen's got a fast car
well volkswagen volkswagen owns bugatti
oh they have
no they own bugatti like they have a
good cars oh [ __ ] yeah they make great
cars
i had a guy i said to him i got how fast
that car goes i'm from [ __ ] lotus
he goes he looks at me he goes never
really opened her up
[ __ ] off you just wanted to say that
yeah
[ __ ] off oh man there's mike because he
gets that question a lot
now see here's the prompt see that one
has 690 horsepower my hand's over 900.
you have the gt3 i think that's that's a
liability on the track gt2 rs
why shock package it's not yeah i don't
i like
like 980 horsepower yeah i like jay's
car right there
oh he has one two damn his gt3 i like
the 911 turbo s's those are cool
yeah does he right drive his car every
day every night
all-wheel drive no uh porsches are
though sometimes so you can get them
yeah
you want that gender right uh no he has
a
he has a uh what's he have he's a uh
uh [ __ ] the for the big ford the the
truck raptor
yeah is that a honda chin no
i don't want my car getting tail happy
now let's go
no hondas aren't good this is a honda
there you go
seven two hundred fifteen seconds oh and
now is that is that some secret fountain
that's like effect
like they're saying that's one of the
fastest track time that's pretty much
good what is that what do we care about
what is that thing though the honda
civic i had a terrible car
no they're great cars they're just a lot
of people like buy them like to try and
like like they do like the street
yeah like in trying street racing yeah
that was in super uh
subarus yeah you can't put a fin on the
back of your honda because of course
i can't
is lamborghini still a player in the
field oh yeah
those are the doors and are [ __ ]
monsters
i posted a picture one oh there it is oh
god dammit
rear wheel drive fast slaps porsche 911
gt2 rx yeah
that's what you have it is it is
chin i'm sorry do you see tesla on there
all right what else you got
but he had the sound effects with him i
know you know this
come on brian dude
[Music]
the day you see me pull up in a test i'm
like oh brand started sucking dick
i i would have maybe there's nothing
wrong with tesla no they're good for the
earth
yeah now the batteries though that's the
problem you got to make the nickel and
you got to bring it over from china and
those are a problem with the
fuel that's actually it's actually got a
bigger carbon that's your bigger problem
and you're
then you're humble do you think you're
helping the earth you're not that you're
actually yeah i didn't say anything
about the earth
no you did though yeah no i didn't i
just heard you say yeah but they're good
for the earth
no i didn't use it yes i got a lot of
low
low interest loans from the government
that there's a lot of government
subsidizing going into that car
and that company just know that now you
should try driving it uh without hands
and if the sun hits it the wrong
uh you die now now the new package i
think has a turn by turn thing right so
i might yeah self-driving you're going
to get another tesla i'm always going to
be in a tesla now
really too lazy he's not a good guy it's
easy oh you're not a car
guy got it okay okay there's anything
else you like besides the tesla
or alexis yeah lexus like okay yeah i
like a couch i like a very easy card but
it's never going to be a problem i don't
know
i like touring cars you and i are saying
yeah you like i don't like small cars i
don't like like he loves
heart he likes feeling the road yeah
it's like an athlete like it's tough to
get in your car
dude he drives that [ __ ] thing every
day like in traffic
most people keep that car under a tarp
yeah but then they take it out on the
weekends maybe
no he drives how many ten thousand miles
on [ __ ]
now what does that do to the value i
don't care yeah i
bought it to drive yup sell it and maybe
they hold [ __ ] their valuables
all right what else you got jim enough
about my stupid car so
pete davidson is uh foreshadowing that
he's gonna leave
snl soon he said in a interview that
he couldn't see himself doing what
keenan did which is i think
uh no one stays as long as keenan ten
years
yeah ten year old he's also doing movies
now he just did another movie i think
he's on hulu or amazon only
he's on suicide squad the new one that
one dude no but he he stars in this
movie where it's this young kid and he
was like uh
oh that came out during the painting
yeah it's a good movie he had his own
movie too king of staten island that was
good
in it great movie i love that he's doing
much
he says that he's surprised he even made
it this far into his
career with that kenan's like [ __ ]
carmalone out there
18 seasons some people stayed for a long
time that's all that's
kenan's keenan
it's a lot of work no what's someone
like keenan making off
that's what i was going to ask you how
much are they making i don't think
hollywood's comfortable but
most of you guys leave because
hollywood's like yeah you're a movie
star now yeah like you're like
sandler spade yeah you'd be surprised
chubby chase
like all the big boy bill murray chris
rock all the big boys
lose use it as a launching pad
i don't think kanan's uh getting any
big-time hollywood offers
although he was in the new trolls he has
a show right now coming up yeah
he's talking about the series yeah yeah
yeah sitcom yeah is it good i haven't
like i said
hollywood's not knocking down his door
there's a reason why he's there 18 years
but he's getting 25 000 per episode and
how many episodes do they do
they do one a week right yeah but but
they take time off
like that's not 52 weeks out of the year
is that pretty good for
an episode what would you say that's
perhaps the 25 grand
that's pretty good yeah let's get money
yeah so he's doing fine
oh yeah no one says struggling
financially yeah it's a lot of work man
seven grand
yeah they're not nobody's making as much
money as you think let's put it that way
is that good money for tv though uh no
no no
there used to be because what the
friends cast that's that's money i
i'm the my salary the first year of mad
tv i was making 7 500 bucks
i'm a week which was a lot of money but
but it wasn't
compared to sitcoms so then i did a
sitcom and i made 35 grand a week
my uh inside schwartz i think it was you
made a lot of money on sitcoms when you
got to stay common it went
what what am i talking about what about
like new sitcoms like when you did uh
goldbridge were you making i was
i i was know that daddy's making daddy
was making pretty good money
because i took you money though no but
but only because yep
but then i got schooled and that was
real money that was really that was real
yeah i remember that so you know when
you didn't get it we both started crying
but then they brought it back
and it felt like i didn't start crying
you felt bad but i've been through it so
many times that i didn't even
i started crying i didn't even miss a
beat yeah i really didn't though
because i i was just so used to it i
tried a little bit yeah
together no i didn't quite then they
were so bummed you were bummed from me
but i was so
but then they called back and greenlit
yeah that's right
so there we were yeah i had such a great
time yeah you cried though
you cried one of my favorite times how
much if you don't mind me asking how
much did you get for entourage
seven dollars no money yeah really yeah
i mean it was a recurrence i never even
paid attention
maybe twenty two hundred bucks i don't
remember they paid me i think they paid
me
to show us five grand i think four forty
five hundred they paid me a hundred
fifty dollars to
star in sicario yeah or uh what was
what's the [ __ ] thing
actually i got 127 dollars i think
127 dollars if you're an i
i had to cry in that i did two episodes
the first episode i had to cry
i had to be crying hysterically for four
hours
oh and i'm not joking because he had to
be he his whole life is done he's been
fired
christians balls
i'm actually working on getting kevin
dylan and kevin on kind of like great
yeah it's great they're all good yeah i
have good dudes man
i've seen that show or whatever his name
is jerry ferrara i've seen that show so
many times i can literally quote
almost every single episode and i love
that but
we can't have much what else you got
jeff
wait how much did you make for uh sex in
the city
i don't remember nothing not much at all
nothing crazy when i did that show it
was such a big deal
it was such a big deal you know so so
many of those shows like you know and
we you think that when you do a [ __ ]
like that you're going to go on to do
something else and yeah i heard that
ryan murphy who created american
horror story and big time and he said i
heard
that he like he thought i was great in
it and so your agents are like ryan
murphy called her
about hopefully parlays in something
else you're like maybe i'll get a part
how much you get paid to do old school
and wedding crashes
i didn't do wedding rushes but the
hangout but oh yeah so i made it i made
a thousand dollars for hangover and and
for hangover two i think i made 25 grand
or something but then you get residuals
then what happens is it's worth 200
grand
over the long haul or you know even more
daddy's going through a divorce so let's
not
put it out there oh no you don't want
them to come sniffing when you have when
you're in california that's all put out
there anyway oh really
yeah but i don't care i i gave yeah
take it keep it it's my kids keep it
[ __ ] take it they're more important
than i am take it
i'm in it why are you doing that we
didn't even do it lawyers we just did
like mediation [ __ ] yeah man
what else you got jen so i don't know
what this car
really means or anything but uh it is
rumored that beyonce and jay-z have
commissioned a 28 million car and it's a
rolls-royce like the
boat one yeah i've seen this yeah it's
the look at how [ __ ] beautiful she is
yeah she's a dime piece jesus christ he
cheated on her how about that
i always tell you everybody you get sick
of vanilla ice cream man
damn it there's no ice cream to us she's
a damn that's a 28 million dollar car
yeah definitely pay for that that's
amazing
it's cool it's like my favorite looks
like blue it looks like a phantom though
yeah it looks like a regular convertible
phantom
it's just a special edition one i never
get really getting the rolls royce
the suv i dig oh that umbrella picnic
out the back that you never use
yeah i'd rock that [ __ ] to be honest
you're not so luxury cars are not that
much they don't get
i the car i want next is a new bentley
gt
really yeah the bentley truck is
so nice how many of those nicotine
patches do you do
i go through a can a day you do yeah is
that bad for you
no you can't tell how they're all over
the damn place yes they'll just throw
them
wait have you talked to the doctor about
that it's all good yeah you got life
insurance
no i have to get life insurance because
you take the nicotine patches no but
they were like oh you take nicotine
patches
it's not good for you it's not bad for
you there's no it's tobaccolus
huh it's just straight nicotine yeah
daddy's about to deal with be cool
zens no i'm doing [ __ ] rogue dude the
only
how much percent nicotine are those
these are six milligrams i use three of
them
18 milligrams you get a buzz at first
when you first do it oh yeah daddy gets
buzzed oh
when you like if i just took one right
now i get a buzz there there it is
no i do not damn damn all that all that
[ __ ] scares me
really yeah i freaked out over stuff
yeah i forgot about it
drink coffee yeah yeah brandon has used
this
to his body yeah
you're not afraid of it no you just let
you run through that big old body of
yours
yeah what else you got jen me and chin
do kratom all the time
i know that's why are you still doing
kratom yeah every day every day every
day yeah dude look at it how's that
thriving you're doing it too look at
them every day hold on so you're doing
kratom you're doing nicotine
yep sometimes other stuff yep
holy [ __ ] massive a lot of coffee a lot
of coffee blood pressure through the
roof it's got to be through the roof
through the roof but you know what
made it this far yeah old dogs it's good
for your brain though
that's what they said what kratom no no
nicotine
yeah nicotine nicotine is good for the
brain that's what they say yeah all the
research
yeah that's why i started it well
i'll google that after this make sure
you can look it up yeah this isn't a
christian's brother
fact that's what i was that's what i was
saying so you had an issue with
booze yeah you could put it down huh
yeah yeah well
oh well yeah i don't do it anymore you
could draw oh god yeah well
oh the dark side comes out dark side is
that right yeah
really yeah all that all that your
childhood yes
all of it always comes up so you might
start
fighting or you just get kind of bashy
uh you should get angry
and stand office for people don't want
to talk to nobody do backflips
just do black folks right i used to do
backwards drunk all the [ __ ] time
wow like with the ease yeah
i mean thick tiger whiskey [ __ ] off
now do you do
now i do drink when yellowstone's on
okay and papa just starts season one so
we'll see
my buddy jeff but you don't you don't
drink it no my buddy's jeff
my buddy jeff we're we're out drinking
jeff fully the greatest and yeah i love
him
and uh we go to pour up the i didn't go
to park
and i go like it's like oh i'm good and
joe go see that you see what you just
did
no i've never done that yeah i've never
done that right yeah now jeff can drink
jeffrey
james have a job jeffy drink three
bottles that's the guy i met him
because jefferson has all the money
smartest guy you know the smartest guy
tiger's birthday party yeah the best
that guy yeah yeah he wrote handsome
[ __ ] yes his wife is his daughter
jeff foley has he's he's one of those
guys handsome as [ __ ] athletic
successful as [ __ ] and all that and and
a
great father his kids couldn't be doing
better by the way his kids couldn't be
doing better great
married loves his wife the whole thing
but
this also a punk rocker yeah he does put
down three bottles of wine and then
also the next morning hung over 90 miles
yup at 11 30 at night he's like this
he's going
[ __ ] i guess i gotta open this one you
know the doctor was like
very he's got abs shape yeah doctor goes
good stuff you look great
um how many drinks do you have a week
and jeff goes you know probably
eight and the doctor goes
you your liver enzymes you sure and jeff
goes you want the real number do you
want to go
you want the real number they can tell
yeah you want the real number i tried
myself
it's about 100 yeah well whatever it was
but he's functional you know yeah he's
hungry
very very nice guy no i love talking to
him yeah that guy's got it he's not
he's actually not an alcoholic i'm not
dramatic yeah like he can he
but that's just one that's not one this
is one vice no he didn't stop at any
time
yeah i would say that was probably like
the vice
yeah i don't have it we're gonna go to
wally's with him listen we're gonna go
oh you can't drink
[ __ ] because what he'll do is he'll go
wally's now this is what i like to do
and you go
uh i want the best and we'll get these
crazy wines that the salmon i go but
that's
expensive i don't care and i don't care
that's what i like to do and they just
pay
did you did you do drugs too no i was i
wasn't
nothing though i hate it i hate mine's a
food man drugs drugs was you never
snored anything
i i sort of coke some sort of
i mean you're not going to do all that
[ __ ] whisper but that was that was
that was
cool i mean i only did cocaine twice you
know what i mean but alcohol was the
[ __ ]
a bunch of my friends said mushrooms was
a big thing i wasn't hitting me up
from the phone and i was like all right
yeah i'm not a bit yeah
yeah i don't like stuff like yeah i
don't know i'm not being drug guy
anything because i was always terrified
of like drugs because of like uh your
brother
no my uh heart you're bad taking i was
yeah bomb ticker
no i was uh the high blood pressure when
i found out i had
high blood pressure when i was like 18
because i almost got a fight at this new
school that i went to
and my chest was then some dude was
throwing ice and he
he didn't realize he that he was [ __ ]
with [ __ ] with the wrong ones the
wrong guy
yeah and uh i remember i was i was so
hyped and just so angry
my chest was like pumping and it
wouldn't stop
and then the security guard said hey
he's like hey man you could you know you
could stop
pumping your chest up and i was like i
can't help it and then i went to
the nurse what you were doing what do
you mean you were doing this it was like
like help like almost palpitating or
whatever and then i went to the nurse
he was like well let's take you to the
nurse he was like how are you feeling
are you okay i was like
i was like i feel fine but i was like i
just can't stop you know
my heart won't stop and then uh went to
the nurse
and uh they took my blood pressure and i
had to leave
yeah i had to leave school right away so
are you on medication no i got off of
that [ __ ]
because because i i don't like i don't
[ __ ] with medication like that because i
was like man what
i was like that was because i was like
how long do i have to take it yeah and
they're like forever
they're they're like they just didn't
say anything i was like ah that's kind
of it just felt weird to me
but once you got all the stress out of
your life i'm sure yeah and everything
because because um it used to be like
when i would go in for my blood like
the checkups i do i go every year i go
to the doctor and get a checkup
and uh my blood pressure would always
like be high at first they have to check
it twice but every
but like within the past like two or
three years every time i've gone
chill good all good good first try all
right yeah your blood pressure might
have been spiked because that fight
yeah is levels were adrenaline yeah yeah
but also he has high blood pressure you
had high blood pressure still do
but you stopped i thought you were well
it went down for sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah ever since then it's
like it's
i've been that's the happiest it's been
i just had my problems
i'll take this pre-workout good blood
pressure though yeah yeah you're
chilling
i'll take this pre-workout in my heart i
can it will beat out of my chest
see this you're taking too many
stimulants yeah yeah no doubt
you're right the big man you know this
is not good yeah yeah no what are you
doing
i know you see you what am i doing you
see me in the gym
i don't use no pre-workout look at me
i'm in the gym if you if you sleep
that i hit 400 i'm not going for 400.
but maybe you should
how many times do you think you could
have done 400 you did it for four
is that true yeah i'm gonna do four you
do this for four four fifteen or four or
five this week that's
and you have long arms yeah that's not
that's that's hard because your
arms are so [ __ ] long hey what'd i do
this morning
275. now does mark four five
does mark tell you that you're really
strong i don't know every day he doesn't
tell me
he tells him it every day i'm not like k
martial but he ain't listening no i
don't give a [ __ ] no but i'm saying
i'm saying i feel like you're strong
weird strong
in comparison i don't know every time i
see it i go what the [ __ ] i mean because
you for a guy i mean if you were
if you were juicing and it was your job
it might be different but
for a guy who you've been living a long
time that's that is
strong as [ __ ] would you first start
weight training
fourth grade have you ever maxed out on
on deadlift no what's the heaviest
you've ever done do you have any idea
600 something it was about
colorado what the [ __ ] 600 you know what
i was doing in fourth grade
cocaine backflip fighting teacher yeah
yeah but chappelle you were that
the [ __ ] you were doing on that [ __ ]
that's crazy athleticism talking about
the cheerleading at 205
oh he brought his world it is a world
championship ring he brought this oh
yeah i brought it to the gym that's nice
no [ __ ] ain't real silver though yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] no that's sick i got
the title
it does say it does say world champion i
wish i had like the sound effects like
you
but i don't have it it was funny though
because i was talking john wayne what's
nasty jam we don't say world champ
remember ask him chivalry
so he gave mark the rink and mark goes
what should we do today
what are you thinking today i'm like oh
[ __ ] you brought the world championship
and it's what does it say on it it says
world champion is my girl jambo with you
right now
no did you wear lauren landau i what did
you work out with lauren landau no he
just came here he held my back a lot
when i saw him last time my back was so
[ __ ] up one's the best
what does he do like he's the strength
coach for the he's just like he's a guy
with the broncos where are you gonna be
their strength you know they just signed
him a five-year extension too
wow you know you're sure your chronicles
are getting aaron rodgers wait what
he's the strength and conditioning coach
hold on is that is that breaking news
that's around the water cooler
that's around the water cooler didn't
tell me that but i'm just saying
yeah the broncos might be getting either
i'm winking or i got a jeff business
all right you heard me
can you cross your eyes there you go no
that's not it yeah he did it he's doing
it right now no he's not it is let me
see you do it
let me see yeah it's good that's oh
that's good god i wish you looked like
that
[ __ ] you what's this kid doing can you
cross your eyes cat
yeah let me see oh okay that's good you
just kiss your jeans
i can't my contacts will look pop out if
i try oh you wear glasses
can you i can't tell you what are you
gonna do
i'll do it watch oh yeah yeah
sure all
i was married to her she's literally all
dead serious she goes up she goes
i had no idea chin was that handsome
thank you
she's attracted to asian men yeah oh
yeah yeah oh she likes the asian
oh persuasion i think she's she dated a
couple of pages
okay seeing a woman one was a
photographer and yeah
so she likes asians huh yes chin's
taking those so
back off yeah what else you got okay
so this guy is a graffiti artist in new
york
and he made a mistake by essentially
tagging over
a dead graffiti legends work
around a punk [ __ ] what went viral is
that he went on his instagram story and
this is a compilation of it he basically
shows himself bloody he says
i hate new york even though he says he
was born and raised there
he then is seen in a cop car saying that
he's looking for the people who jumped
him
so let me see we don't have video him
getting jumped no
[ __ ] yeah oh
it's just a bloody nose it hate new york
i'm not doing graffiti for a while yeah
you're graffiti culture
we could wipe your face off find this
[ __ ]
you know but a lot of people are giving
them [ __ ] because they're saying you're
not supposed to tag
over like it's similar to surfing where
like certain people will surf on the big
waves and you have to kind of get the
respect of the locals to start
surfing on that area it's similar with
tagging where you're not supposed to tag
in certain areas as a
up-and-comer you kind of go to random
spots and as you work your way up the
food chain then you can kind of tag
where you want
and he made the mistake of tagging over
um a previous legends
area and so somebody saw jumped him
and he went viral because he's trying to
rap people out
and he's saying that he had to do it
he's making up a story saying
he says as far as it goes in regards to
tagging over zer
zexer if i had known who it was i
wouldn't have done it the man is a hero
to me and my bad i didn't recognize the
piece in the rush
i was in to get my tag up i'm laughing
at y'all don't say y'all
telling me i don't know graph graffiti
culture when the man's literally had
docks of himself talking about tagging
over people [ __ ] with his face exposed
i looked up to him i took notes i'm i'm
[ __ ]
from new york born and raised the paint
from my cans ain't ever gonna wash off
these hands
that was cool y'all don't like my work
good y'all call me a rat good
y'all make me famous even better you
want to get tight at me because i'm
trying some new [ __ ] that's chill be
basic i love this city but i stand by
what i said this shit's toxic
y'all out here talking about raping my
moms and killing me nah not my new york
well he doesn't talk like that his
name's bozo his name is bo
boza got beat up and pregnant yeah and
then a bunch of people went on to his
instagram started sending him hate so he
limited his comments
uh my buddy dave sent this to me kristen
cavallari and uh jay cutler apparently
jay cutler the reason why the divorce is
taking so long is because he wants half
of her company
well she gets out for his uh football
pay right
i'm not sure no i think this is how it
works
this is a slick move right yeah i mean
she got half of his [ __ ] and he
had she wasn't throwing footballs you
were shooting in the gym
so there you go yep that's it
system he should get stake in the uj
because he launched it when they were
married yeah if you were living together
under the same roof that's they started
yeah oh
like if you start a company when you're
married like she's going to get half of
that so why wouldn't he get half
that's why it's like why wouldn't you do
it yeah dude
divorce has enough money so much money
of course they do that's
terrible and then they'll sometimes like
they'll just drag it out and they'll get
together with
each other and they're like what
happened to me oh you put a straight in
his mouth
don't do that again
[Music]
oh she got jedi pee so hard all right
one more yeah
well so this is a private school and a
per
apparently these are first graders that
are getting taught this stuff in a video
it's about like masturbation and sex
that's not good and i'll just play a
clip for you
let me find a good area here
this is first grade yep urethra it helps
us eat
how come my penis gets big sometimes and
points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels
good sometimes when i'm in my bath or
when mom puts me to bed
i like to touch my vulva too you have a
clitoris there kayla so it's kind of
they're teaching them at first grade
level that might be a little [ __ ]
also who's the ratchet teacher there why
is she all like hood
the ratchets yeah you see the girl's
like oh that's you don't let your
parents talk
without your consent that's another
thing that they're upset about yeah
[ __ ]
they're telling the kids not to let
their parents touch them without consent
[ __ ] man
what it's like you have a child yeah you
don't know what the [ __ ] these people
don't have children these are bad people
take my kid out of here yes
they're paying like people fifty
thousand a year for this one yeah
they're bad i would take their
dumbest [ __ ] and they're bad people they
don't yeah they're probably people that
don't have mom goes i'm paying fifty
thousand these [ __ ] tell my kids not
to let her grandfather hug her when he
sees her another
[ __ ] these people don't have
kids she'd get cancelled these
[ __ ] i pull my kids so fast at school
i'd keep them there and fight
i'm off to miami for the logan paul
floyd mayweather fight this week but
next week i'm in oklahoma city with
chappelle lacey
and david lucas oklahoma city oklahoma
brickstown economy club june 10th
through the 12th
and then end of july pittsburgh tickets
will be on sale this week for the
pittsburgh improv
that's end of july and then denver
colorado mama i'm coming home september
3rd mama i'm coming home
there you go uh yeah i think sick boy
dropped too thick boy merch of thick boy
hoodies
thick boy long sleeve tees and my
favorite hats of all time thick boys oh
those are nice hats
yeah i got you dog i'll never wear a hat
i don't think i've ever seen the hat
exactly all right so don't stay nice uh
lol comedy club this this san antonio
san antonio
thursday friday saturday let's go let's
go we'll see you there this weekend i
got albany june 18 19.
conspiracy social club on rockfin now
rockfin.com
conspiracy social club big and hungry
dropped today it's a funny one with
steve burn and i
philadelphia pa helium june 25 26 27
we'll see you there
let's go oh and you're in appleton i'm
in appleton wisconsin this weekend the
fourth and fifth
who's there skyline comedy club with
justin elliott
the man with all the fashion then july
15th through the 17th i'll be in
baltimore maryland baltimore
there you go and the goobies joking tell
me how that is
i want to know i hear a lot of great
things about the club so
that's it i'm excited love you guys god
bless everybody